bonsoir did my pouch Stewart brand and
Alexander Rose is going to introduce the
speakers tonight so I get to introduce
the long short and it relates to
something you can conjure with little
later this evening after our adventures
underground in Paris tonight there will
be a reception over in the long now
Museum and shop and office
and bar to be spirits various kinds of
things that jack you up in sideways
coffee and tea and conversation and
discussion what happened is Alexander
rose noticed that the space is fabulous
on occasions like this evenings after
talks here at the collar but frankly
most of the time during the day it's
really quiet in there and most evenings
it's really quiet in there but one of
the peculiarities of being on federal
land is that you don't need to get a
liquor license to sell life
so let's roll this this video
[Music]
I'm Alexander Rose the director at the
long now foundation I'm excited to tell
you about a new project we are working
on it long now we would like to invite
you to help us build our new gathering
space we opened our small Museum and
book store here in Fort Mason in 2006 to
show some of our projects like the
10,000 year clock the seminars about
long-term thinking and the Rosetta
project since then we have seen some of
the best connections and conversations
about long-term thinking at our
receptions and gatherings so in
collaboration with our partners here at
Fort Mason in the amazing design-build
studio because we can we have designed a
salon space that will not only house our
prototypes and a hand curated library
but also serve locally roasted coffee by
day and inspired cocktails by night open
daily this space will be a venue for
salon Talks demonstrations and
collaborative events but now we have to
raise the funds to build it we would
like to engage you our friends and
members along with some amazing local
artisans in a campaign that is hopefully
as compelling for you to participate in
as it has been for us to create st.
George spirits in Alameda has created
two exclusive spirits for us each one is
truly a distillation of long term
thinking the first is an aromatic gin
made with juniper berries harvested by
hand among the five thousand-year-old
bristlecones from our site in Eastern
Nevada
[Music]
the other spirit is a whiskey with a
specially tailored grain bill it will be
fermented and distilled in such a way
that it will be delicious without aging
and grow more intricate and complex with
every year we will bottle a small amount
each year for the next 15 years allowing
you to taste its annual progression each
of these spirits will be kept at our
space for you in the Japanese bottle
keep tradition they are stored on
permanent display in a custom vessel by
Adams and Chittenden when you arrive the
bartender will lower your bottle for you
to enjoy it straight or mixed in a
cocktail of your choice we are offering
two levels for you to participate
the founders bottle and the 15-year
whiskey club but just to be clear this
space is about more than just coffee and
cocktails the goal is to build a social
space to help make long-term thinking
more automatic and common rather than
difficult and rare we are excited about
bringing you all together in a new space
and a new conversation please join us
and help us build it
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you all these levels are not low
levels but we do encourage you to go in
on them that the founders bottle where
it's a sum of this Bristlecone gin that
they have made where it's kept for you
up in the ceiling and the kind of like a
chandelier of liquor is $1500 we
encourage you to go in on it with other
people if you want to some also
something some people are having their
companies buy it so that their employees
can enjoy it when they come there and
the 20 foot or the 15 year whisky Club
is $25,000 there's only 12 of those
available but hopefully if once we reach
about half of this fundraising goal
we're going to start construction and
we'll be we hope to be able to pull it
all off this year so thank you tonight's
speakers are you know normally we have a
single speaker not two they were kind of
hard to come by it seems my whole life
I've heard about the Paris underground
catacombs and how amazing they were and
some cases I've gotten a chance to see
little glimpses of them and I was dimly
aware that there were groups that were
kind of hacking into them but it really
wasn't until I read John Lachman 's
article in Wired that I realized that
what the Paris urban experiment was
doing was fundamentally different than
all the urban explorer groups that I'd
ever seen or heard they were actually
undertaking cultural heritage
restoration without permission and as we
all know permission is basically
impossible to get but forgiveness is
usually much more much much more
available and these guys have taken that
principle to a new extreme that that I
had never seen before and that that they
were seeing the cultural fires burning
on these artifacts over but they were
seeing the kind of catastrophes that we
usually see in an earthquake they were
seeing them taking
for decades and not only just seeing it
and recognizing it but intervening in a
very positive and careful way and so I
realized this was very much a long now
topic especially because one of their
restoration projects was a clock and so
I knew and I had to get them here but
there's kind of a fundamental problem in
a secret restoration group is that they
are secret and so I got in touch with
some friends of mine at Wired who then
got in touch me with got me in touch
with John and and John said yeah I've
been getting a lot of requests to
contact these guys they don't answer
them just so you know but I'll forward
it on don't get your hopes up
and the next day I my cell phone was
ringing and it was a Paris phone number
and it was Lazar and Lazar said that he
thought long now would be the perfect
place for their one and only public
presentation
so that was my response the the other
challenge of this presentation is that
Lazar and the whole group are very much
they they actually work in a very small
section of Paris and very few of them
speak very much English
his English is is a little better than
than my French which isn't saying an
awful lot so he and John wrote a
presentation together John is going to
give the presentation Lazar is going to
run the slides that they put together as
well as a really great video so bear
with us it's not it's not the usual type
of presentation but the content is
amazing and I really appreciate you
coming up thank you very much thank you
for coming out tonight everyone welcome
Thank You Alexander for that great
introduction and I'm just gonna dive
right in we want to talk tonight about
cultural heritage so what is the this
strange idea cultural heritage
well we'd say cultural heritage refers
to a multitude of objects sites and even
concepts that all share a particular
designation that is to say they are all
considered to be important symbols of
some civilization living or dead these
symbols don't perfectly illustrate the
culture that gave birth to them they
just mark a few points along its contour
the objects described by the umbrella
term heritage represent just a few
rescued fragments of course only a time
machine could offer a complete picture
therefore cultural heritage must be
defined as traces that reveal the
construction of our civilizational
present traces that survived either by
chance or because our ancestors intended
them to which is to say that they
engaged in long-term thinking the
clearer and more numerous those traces
are the more we have to compare with our
present era and know more precisely we
can
our possible futures if we fail to try
at least as hard as our predecessors to
preserve that heritage well we condemn
our children and our grandchildren to
myopia if not total blindness regarding
their own future but let's get down to
brass tacks whose job is it to conserve
heritage when we speak of cultural
heritage we generally speak of it as
belonging to someone it's a nation's
heritage it's a region's heritage city's
heritage etc this manner of speaking can
lead you to believe that all cultural
heritage has an owner a city a nation a
continent if only a temporary one we
think of this heritage as being passed
on from generation to generation sort of
like a family heirloom but the
timelessness of heritage destroys that
possibility of designating a true owner
or owners in truth heritage only has
managers people who can't profit from
its use the way they could if they owned
it but people who must nonetheless
assure its survival so whether we talk
about ownership or responsibility the
question remains whose is whose
ownership whose responsibility the
beginnings of an answer to this question
can be found in the expression world
heritage which is used most notably by
UNESCO and what this expression world
heritage suggests is that the more
important cultural heritage is by virtue
of its artistic richness or the
importance of its information or its
remoteness from the present or its
rarity the more important it is the more
widespread responsibility for it is
shared an extreme version of this
argument would say that all physical and
oral testimony of the paths taken by the
human race is valuable to the entire
world and thus is the responsibility of
all people living today now there's a
less extreme version of that argument
that's arguably superior and the way
that argument goes is the less a piece
of global cultural heritage concern
all the world cultures the more locally
its responsibility is shared in this
case responsibility for it falls on a
reduced circle of individuals who are
linked to that heritage by relevant
cultural preoccupations so allow me for
a moment to schematize in caricature a
little what this implies with a
hypothetical example take a village bell
tower now this tower is unlikely to
persist and survive and transmit its its
historical and architectural content to
the next generation it's unlikely to
survive if the villagers themselves
aren't given and don't take
responsibility for that conservation but
this less prestigious heritage such as
the bell tower which we could call minor
heritage is it really of minor
importance
if you tallied up all the world's
cultural heritage you'd find that the
minor pieces form the vast majority of
the whole not just a number but also in
diversity and richness of information
and inability to give us the most
precise possible image of our past in
our evolution so minor heritage
represents not just the largest portion
of global cultural heritage it's also
the heritage that touches individuals
most directly now unfortunately the
conservation of cultural heritage
usually pursues a fatalist objective
which is to say to let as little
disappear as possible that's usually the
objective but this objective leads
inevitably to a notion of prioritization
or triage in a rationing of efforts made
to conserve each piece of heritage
famous or not the most common approach
the conservation takes is to privilege
the most prestigious pieces of heritage
found in a given region or culture and
the problem with this approach is that
what's most prestigious today isn't
necessarily what will most interests men
and women of tomorrow for example a
steward brand has described in his
writings for certain periods of ancient
Chinese history we have hundreds of
records of the religious philosophical
thought of the time
but yet not one record of what men's and
women's lives were actually like at that
time what they ate for breakfast
whom they loved how they loved what they
thought of the politics of their day so
on and most of us would gladly trade one
of those religious philosophical texts
for one of a different kind so if it's
true that we can't know what will
interest future generations
what's even more true is that over the
very long term absolutely everything
will eventually be of interest to
someone and it's truly pointless to try
to figure out what today will interest
the men and women of tomorrow and so on
some level absolutely everything
deserves to be conserved and every time
one chooses not to conserve something
something is lost our selection process
may seem to have a kind of logic but
ultimately it's arbitrary it arises
post-hoc most often as a kind of
rationalization that serves to make us
feel better about the choices that we've
already made so we mustn't pretend that
nothing is lost when something is deemed
not worth saving we have to accept the
uncomfortable truth that there's no
truly rational way to decide what should
be saved now at the same time choices
must be made of course to conserve to
try to conserve everything is ultimately
to conserve nothing so all that said our
descendants will be most likely to thank
us if the things that survive are as
diverse as possible as numerous as
possible and as direct as possible in
their testimony which is to say we
should strive to save things that
provide firsthand material evidence of
what life was like back then the most
famous pieces of heritage don't
necessarily deserve to suck up all of
our conservation resources because the
most famous pieces are the most
brilliant artistically and historically
and thus the most rare the least
representative and thus in some sense
the least educational so considering
minor cultural heritage in this way
necessarily leads the following question
if the term minor cultural heritage is
defined as that which is visible to
relatively few people what should we
call heritage that is visible to
absolutely no one at all
heritage that has been completely
forgotten about invisible heritage non
visible heritage would be a more
appropriate term because the state
usually isn't incurable it's not an
inborn thing it results rather from a
confluence of circumstances that end up
removing the heritage from view in some
cases this heritage may still be
technically visible to the eye but no
one notices it anymore so non visibility
need not be permanent it's only not
visible for time non visible heritage
may not represent the majority of
heritage but like minor heritage it is
very diverse and deeply enmeshed in its
local context and therefore very
valuable now hear the question of who is
responsible for conservation is quite
different when we talk about non visible
heritage well there's a certain paradox
I'm talking about it which is to say
that in order for us to talk about it
there must be some exceptions to its non
visibility there must be people
somewhere whose gaze has wandered into
the shadows who have perceived its value
as a witness to an era or an historical
situation to knowledge that's gone or
disappearing to discover whose bear who
bears responsibility for this non
visible heritage we must proceed by
elimination and the answer becomes
immediately apparent this responsibility
can only fall to those people for whom
this non visible heritage is in fact
perfectly visible now let's return for a
moment to the general question of who's
responsible for conservation now it's
somewhat regrettable but in almost all
cases responsibility and the
conservation tasks that responsibility
entails that responsibility is not
spread out evenly know what usually
happens is a system is employed and for
some good reason
we're in the public designates or points
a group of individuals to be in charge
of conservation and to be in charge of
prioritizing conservation goals but in
the case of non-visible heritage who
will appoint someone to conserve it its
existence is by definition known only by
accident and by at most a handful of
people the notion of being appointed
obviously does not apply in this case
however in practice the vast majority of
people who accidentally discover some
piece of non visible heritage they never
think of helping to conserve it because
they feel they lack amended they feel
that no one has granted them permission
no one has appointed them so this fact
condemns these objects to a slow but
sure death and this non visible heritage
becomes disappeared heritage and you can
surely see the difference between those
two states one is reversible other is
not the problem here is that people have
over generalized the very logical and
practical system of appointing
conservators this system is
unfortunately exclusive and any idea
that doesn't fit into it is considered
an inapplicable and this leads to
paralysis when it comes to non visible
heritage but does that systemic vice
make it acceptable for us to let
disappear such important heritage what
would remain today of the historical
record if this fatalism were applied
systematically how can we wriggle free
from this problem though how can we
prevent neglected and insufficiently
known heritage from disappearing one
very simple seeming solution would be to
research a non visible heritage document
it and publicize it and make it visible
in the hope that educating the public
would lead automatically to conservation
now this methods primary defect is that
publicity attracts curiosity seekers
looters and vandals well before it
motivates institutions that are capable
of carrying for that heritage the
authorities inevitably arrived after the
tourists and whether the tourists are
well intentioned or not they lack a
strong commitment to the
it's preservation and so they inevitably
denature or in some cases completely
destroy that heritage making non
divisible heritage visible is more risky
than useful most of the time why don't
these tourists possess a strong
commitment to preservation well you
could say it's because they lack
proximity they aren't close enough to
the heritage they don't see it as
connected to their existence they're
here and now you must perceive heritage
as connected to your here and now in
order to feel that it's natural for you
to try to preserve it and that's true
whether you have a short here and now or
a long here and along now tourists see
only one moment in the site's history
when they arrive and a single snapshot
can only serve as a kind of exotic
entertainment only when you possess a
series of snapshots spread out over time
do you possess something more than
entertainment that's when you possess a
tool then you have a kind of film
instead of a static image you can see
history unfolding in time you have a
tool that permits you to see how the
site has evolved and the ways in which
it might continue to evolve if you have
that historical perspective and if
furthermore you this site is part of
your environment it's something you see
regularly then in that case you can't
intervene in the site's history you can
identify what's worked well at the site
and encourage that development toward
the future likewise you can perceive
what's not worked and endeavor not to
repeat those errors you naturally take a
much more vivid interest in the site but
this film is only a useful tool if you
think of yourself as a character in the
film and not just a spectator if you
don't feel empowered to intervene in the
evolution of your environment you lose
interest in its history and indeed you
barely even perceive the fact that you
have a tool at your at your disposal and
a tool that goes unused is the tool that
rusts and becomes completely unusable so
opportunities to intervene don't exist
everywhere one stumbles into them as
often as one finds them
purpose but what is sure is that if you
don't take advantage of the
opportunities that do come your way some
heritage probably will never get another
chance to survive now if you do
intervene if you study the heritage and
the glimpses it offers of the past you
can help ensure a future in which that
heritage will survive and will continue
to play an active present role in
people's lives using the past in the
present ensures that in the future the
past will be very much present
unfortunately the truth is there's no
blanket solution yet developed for
preserving this kind of non visible
heritage and when solutions do appear
they're always tied to a particular
context so we need to study some
specific examples of course none of
these examples are silver bullets but
the more closely we examine them in
their contexts the larger our toolkit
grows and that toolkit can help resolve
those situations when there's no ready
solution at hand so first example in the
United States consider the case of John
Hebert Steven Fresco's and Scott Hefner
three skilled infiltrators of abandoned
sites such as disused factories
abandoned theme parks so on with time
and experience they've added another
activity to their exploration activity
they inventory and document sites and
objects of historical importance that
are on the verge of demolition
for example the IX 529 C shadow which
was America's first stealth ship an
expensive experimental and never used
craft the C shadow is 28 years old few
if any civilians have ever seen it with
the exception of this trio they
infiltrated its high-security drydock in
Sweden Bay California and there they
passed several weekends visiting this
ship and the 80 others alongside it
which formed the so-called mothball
fleet ships that the Navy no longer uses
and is slowly scrapping the sea shadow
itself is slated for demolition
even though really few other objects can
convey the scale and secrecy of the Cold
War so this kind of industrial
archeology is a great example of self
granted responsibility and contextual
problem-solving being used to prevent
the total and irreversible disappearance
of cultural heritage that has had the
misfortune to fade from view now before
I proceed to the next example I need to
make a general observation which is one
reason why non visible heritage is non
visible and neglected in the first place
is that most public things are neglected
today not just public spaces but also
public action public reflection the very
notion of the public the note that the
notion of collectivity now I hope the
next example will show is that if you
back up a little bit an attack the
broader problem of the neglect of the
public sphere you resolve nearly
automatically all of that problems
consequences the consequence that
interests us most is the neglect of
minor and non visible cultural heritage
so the next example concerns some 30
years of history and it's about a group
of people that started making use of
neglected public space not for
conservation at first but for all kinds
of other activities and the conservation
arose more or less by accident in fact
the more this group used these neglected
public spaces the more it's it's the
more its affection for these spaces grew
and the more familiar it became with
neglected and decaying non visible
heritage inside these spaces now I can't
summarize in a few minutes this groups
entire 30-year evolution and it's
complex context but I want to review
some highlights so let's begin at the
beginning in the early 1980s in Paris a
small group of middle school aged
students in the Latin Quarter conducted
u X's first experiment although they
didn't realize that's what they were
doing at the time they let themselves be
locked inside the Pantheon after
so the pantheon is this building in the
Latin Quarter that used to be a church
and is now a monument to national heroes
so this excursion into unauthorized
territory open their eyes to the
possibility of a sort of reconquest of
the city's neglected areas certain
favorable Geographic and historical
factors helped that experience to become
the first in a series of consecutive
experiments that took on the name urban
experiment UX for short and these
continue to this day
u X's numbers grew quickly and subgroups
appeared
centered on the various possible uses of
the urban fabric so I first want to talk
about la mexican de paris y'all this is
the name of the ux subgroup devoted to
artistic events concerts plays
exhibitions la mexican explores every
possible way of harnessing neglected
urban sites for innovative events its
best-known work today remains its annual
clandestine film festival this
festival's most distinctive feature
besides its clandestinity is its method
the way that it places films in
comparative perspective by linking them
together in the same evening so they
show two or more films in the same
evening and using this method they
reveal in an intuitive manner certain
essential yet hard to perceive elements
of the films being projected they see
that there's important connection
between these two films and they show
them to you in the hopes that you will
grasp it but they're not explaining it
to you it's supposed to be more of an
intuitive process so the Mexicans first
film festivals mostly took place late at
night in Latin Quarter cinemas but then
the French Cinematheque
located the Trocadero became the site of
the group's flagship festival the
Cinematheque was founded in Paris
decades ago in order to restore and
conserve old films this temple to film
had tremendous symbolic value for them
plus a very convenient location in
the heart of the Shia palace all of
which made it the most welcoming site
for this annual summer Film Festival
which was aptly titled
and you'll have to excuse my Spanish
pronunciation which is almost as bad as
my French pronunciation and that's
titled la sección Komoda one evening
during a viewing of Chris markers logic
day certain members of a Mexican
realized that a certain room in the Shia
palace that holds plaster casts was in
fact the very same room that they had
used that the group had used to get
people into the Cinematheque and this is
the set that the director had used for
his film and this exceedingly
serendipitous coincidence a kind of mess
on a beam as they say in French which is
sort of like the funhouse mirror effect
right this inspired them to create a new
festival exclusively dedicated to views
of the city and this festival was to be
situated backstage as it were in spaces
where one sees the backside of the urban
stage set the hidden side 40 meters away
from the Cinematheque 40 meters as the
crow flies or you might say as the mole
digs the group constructed a complex of
underground rooms sandwiched between the
palaces basement the number 9 subway
line and some old quarry tunnels and
they equipped it with a little screening
room a bar a dining room and various
other amenities this site which they
baptized the Shia arena
sheltered into until 2004 this festival
which they called urbex movies
unfortunately on August 23 2004 an
anonymous telephone call alerted the
authorities to the fact that something
strange was going on underground the
police busted into the Shia arena which
fortunately was empty at the time and to
their very great surprise which was
matched only by their very great in
comprehension that such a thing could
ever exist
they found the sentiment and of course
news of this extraordinary find leaked
out rapidly and forced UX for the first
time in its 23 years at this point to
defend its existence publicly to prevent
rumours from crowding out the truth they
had to resign themselves to answering
questions from annoying journalists like
myself and of course while they were
doing this they were quietly smuggling
out the entire a entirety of the cinema
right out from under the authorities
noses who thought that they were keeping
an eye on the site right all this
equipment was surreptitiously relocated
to a spot that UX had been using for a
very long time the site they'd been
using for the longest of any site the
Pantheon so while it was figuring out
how to project films in this site a
building of course was not designed for
film festivals Mexican resumed one of
the first things it had ever done
Pantheon which was clandestine theater
at the premiere for one of these
productions various UX members arrived
to give their support to the lack of
Mexican to see the production and also
they took advantage of the occasion to
resurvey the site which they hadn't
given a close look in some time and they
discovered that the monument had
degraded badly in those years in a
number of ways but most particularly its
clock had its monumental clock had
degraded and this attracted the
attention of one UX subgroup in
particular the one called winter winter
and how you get to hear my German
pronunciation so you might not guess it
from the group's
basically nonsensical name but entered
winter is the UX group that investigates
how to conserve non-visible heritage and
carries out that conservation it's
difficult to say exactly how old into
Gunther is when did UX begin conserving
heritage well it's a really interesting
question you could say the conservation
begins at the very moment when you
develop an affection strong enough to
lead to conservation
but even that isn't quite right it's
impossible to say when exactly
conservation begins it's a fluid process
with no beginning and no end
let me give you an example of what I
mean say you're in one of your favorite
underground workshops and there's a
stone wall that's listing and
threatening to just like fall on top of
you one day and of course you're saying
to yourself mmm guess I need to do
something about that wall well I could
tear it down I guess build a new brick
wall I don't know that would be the
easiest thing but it would kind of ruin
the feel of the place the aesthetics the
history etc so what do you do okay you
start reading about this kind of stone
wall the history of its construction the
method of its construction how do you
restore it and at this point you've
already begun the process conservation
without even realizing
so as UX began to explore and to use
Parisian urban spaces the group began to
become aware of pieces of non visible
heritage that were badly in need of
conservation and it began to develop an
affection for these things - and this
heritage really ceased to be non visible
in their eyes they saw it very clearly
and so winter winter which typically
focuses on one site per year they had
not planned to devote 2005 to the
Pantheon's clock but their accidental
discovery of its sorry state inspired
them to change their plans the proud
that here's this the problem is that if
you leave a mechanical object immobile
for too long you let it oxidize for too
long eventually it becomes unrestorable
because in the process of D oxidizing
and taking the oxidation off you
inevitably remove some of the original
object and then if you remove too much
of it its properties change and you end
up just having to create a facsimile
instead of restoring the object so this
realization of under Gunther is that
this clock desperately needed attention
to just sum up this discovery resulted
from its continually observing and
maintaining the neglected heritage
together with its permanent occupation
of an abnormal abnormally large swath of
urban terrain so in September 2005 this
near dead clocks urgent need for
intervention left them with an obvious
choice there was no choice at all I mean
they had to do it so almost immediately
winter winter undertook a clandestine
restoration of the Pantheon's clock
under the direction of UX group member
and Parisian clock maker jean-baptiste
vo and in order to be able to do this
restoration on site he and his comrades
installed a temporary clock restoration
workshop in the base of the monument
still very high up in the building in an
area known as u gwk and after a period
of initial research documentation
preparation after that was completed
they disassembled the nineteenth-century
mechanism brought it up to their
workshop and began the restoration
properly called and over the course of
one year completely unbeknownst to the
monuments guards and other employees
went are going to came and wet by day
and night and restored this amazing 1850
vogner clock to its original brilliance
once this work was finished they decided
that it would really be a shame for this
now perfectly operational clock to not
keep time in this
mausoleum for national heroes I mean you
know the dead have a particular need to
know what time it is
and but to whom could they entrust the
task of widening the clock once a week
they can't let them even though it may
seem like a small job they can't let
themselves accumulate new chars after
every restoration because they're just
pile up so working by process of
elimination they decided they had no
choice but to suggest to the monuments
director that he filled this noble
function and as they suspected he loved
the idea unfortunately his superiors did
not and he told them he should not have
done the Center for national monuments
which oversees the pantheon among other
sites fired the director and pseudo
interpreter now fortunately there's no
crime of clock restoration in friendship
nor is it a crime unlike in some
countries it is not a crime in Paris to
trespass on public property it's
considered to belong to the public right
all right
so the administration lost its lesson
and interpreter was acquitted and there
was another consequence which is that
the necessarily public nature of a trial
once again obliged you X to explain its
position to the public so since this
incident transpired just three years
after the whole Shia palace cinema
discovery affair you X decided to
undertake new precautionary measures and
I'm happy to report that since then
they've had no other problems under
Gunther a la Mexican have both
successfully resumed their invisible and
clandestine activities and the trial had
one other upside which is that by making
public certain aspects of you X's
existence it became possible for the
group to assemble from its archives a
film film that you're about to see I
know it can be hard to form a concrete
picture of what you X is different
experiments are like without witnessing
them so I hope this illustration will
make it easier for you so with that
introduction here's the film which is
titled Pantheon users guide
[Music]
you
we do complete justice American MA just
as Mia
[Applause]
[Music]
you fellas what we said
[Applause]
[Music]
look your best movie donating Vincent
femoral it clicks Lavazza yo bear now
present in Mauritania casa de la
rochelle alabama hakushi the clear is a
damage in family sabaki mobility
solution on sweeter duck city under the
american PSA fatigue would require
collaboration of an attack accept any
website for up to the project
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
mm
[Music]
[Applause]
but elusive Kabbalah
daddy
you
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
now you get my message
Jesus yes hilarious that question wasn't
yeah they killing Alan yes that's a fact
that's what exactly did you
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
Simar
you
so to conclude let's return to what you
might say is the central question posed
by this clock rescue operation how is
the clock doing today you might be
surprised to learn that the Pantheon's
clock has returned to its former
occupation and is once again immobile
and slowly oxidizing away indeed the
Center for national monuments has
forcibly kept it in mobile even though
it is as you know now perfectly
operational the fact that the
administration lost its surrealist
lawsuit did not at all inspire it to
reevaluate its behavior let alone atone
for it so what can we take away from
this example what lesson can be drawn
from this experiment to what extent did
it contribute to the preservation of
heritage to the preservation of traces
of our pasts however minor they may be
well perhaps the lesson is that even
failures can prove productive this clock
won't return to its 2005 state of
degradation for several more decades
even if it does remain immobile it will
eventually degrade again assuming no one
intervenes to preserve it again but that
couldn't really happen good thank you
[Applause]
see oh let's put let's are here keys I
got a questions in French can I be heard
a little bit little good that helps
people who speak or write French are
welcome to write questions in French and
send them up and I will be baffled by
them and hand them till those are first
of all crystalline artists are this is
basically all artists no nukes if I go
back to stick see our star donkey saw
something so it's now a group of artists
it's really best defined as a group of
people who conduct experiments together
yes we do experimentation especially
frequency perfect emotional TV it's not
necessarily scientific as a scientific
aspect um speaking generally the people
who have been doing this or what in
their ordinary life and their day jobs
don't come blue all walks of life to
produce it's a secret 30 years is
unusual for anything to continue
businesses don't usually last that long
how young were you when were you at the
beginning 30 years ago I mean any play
within a year of the founding yeah and
the group of people must be somewhat
different over time so this is the same
group of people for decade after decade
no believe on I'll tell you so there's a
third yeah a third of the group it's
people who were there from the beginning
but people have come and gone how many
people this is the most interesting Q&A
session gentleman named Alex s what if
you accidentally break something so yeah
there you are repairing things for you
guys are you know heavy equipment
underground fragile stuff suppose
Christendom Jessica Kosak see don't take
no I just wanna do shows that I thought
that's what significantly para oppressor
no it's a lot of French speakers local
vegetation so they're very careful if
they brave if baby if they break
something then they've got twice as many
things to prepare and conserve and so
there you go um Danielle from long now s
can you ex happen anywhere or despair us
have a unique ability to let your
activities happen through his history
culture architecture that it's not a
crime to trespass on public land it's
Paris unique in this see who fancies up
every could on professor
cocka cocka part out yes on the Canadian
there's a me say yeah yeah
they've never tried anywhere else
they're not sure City supporters have up
the DCU
the only way you can find out is to try
yeah so it's been public since I guess
2000 and when did you do your article so
that was about a year ago more than
naturally any but since it became public
with the trial and so on have there been
other groups and other places doing
things like this do you think
underground San Francisco obesity is
very coca coca para ver para Cicely
collectimus Polly is a spirit remember
do my mother power toaster I don't care
yoki noise on door except we're off at
so yeah if if they inspired someone and
they inspired them correctly then
they're keeping everything that they're
doing secret and there is no way for
Lazar to know about
[Applause]
there are hundreds of such groups I
understand and they're always in yeah
what do you got for me
oh yeah
gentlemen same name show it looks like
your Johnny says if I know someone who
does similar illegal restoration here in
San Francisco would Lazar like to meet
them Holly is here see II see a San
Francisco the paper a
it's the wrong country a second secular
lyrics functions if I guess you don't
and issues compatibly so that's how you
expose um is that it's by aggregating
together people who are involved in
similar activities most of the growth
has come about because the group has
noticed people who are up to something
that they saw as compatible with their
own activity and they then initiated the
discussion about joining forces so it
the most kind of dramatic aspect of this
is the underground aspect and / seems
they have an unusual amount of Paris
below ground in these neglected spaces
and so on could you say something about
that
yep Eric Paree
Telmo booked this pass so to sit there
because
dear captures what a su ways of
asafetida context favorable instead yeah
yeah context historic she did have a
silver Honda no see cetera so mondo it
is about easy to jump in auto body fat
difference if you yell at don't see to
see this with
so right so one of the favorable
conditions that has helped us to grow is
that yes there are a tremendous number
of spaces underground that if there are
some of them very historical and
interesting and there's a a density to
them as well where they're just you can
yes you can encounter a large number of
them in it in a small area
don't use phenom below said Felice were
partially on this earth we don't keep it
connected onto right so the even more
important than these areas being
numerous is the fact that they are all
so close together that they can easily
be interconnected and so the group has
over time created interconnections
between all the various spaces that
exist underground and so they can do
almost anything that they want to do
they can get from one place to another
circulating completely underground never
having to go above above ground that's
very attractive area of processes have
done much deeper query to the crystals
issues reported in Georgia contain s
Poston proficient at his master's Roger
Oh
so why was it written on the Pantheon
directors door saucy soup
meaning you know no exit forbidden to
enter yeah right so but that wasn't the
director pile-up what do you eat oh this
is Lisa a ball so as I thought it was
the security as per saw professor Yana
is post-christian upon so the pasta
factory that is great is that his idea
of professionalism
you'd be the director as I recall we
talked in Paris a couple months ago
and you let the director know about the
clock and advised you not to tell
anybody else and he then made the
mistake of telling his superiors is that
how it played out or a little more
compost kid you know you dated my dad
once we don't have a Labour Party CP I
only have to play a tool model he told
he told everyone what had happened he
was so proud this memo the forensics and
petite adjourn except L happened to
Jacques Pascal money fool a surplus eco
Lobby on students to promote Alizee a
look how safe over forever right so yeah
the the real problem was that his deputy
wanted his boss's job and took advantage
of this opportunity to slide his boss
out the door that's English what
happened to the directors she's still a
friend of UX or who knows
no problem catch a VC detective yeah I
tried to contact him when I was writing
my article with that luck I mean he
basically was sort of pushed into early
retirement and no one's heard from him
since I don't think Harry Haller asks
many urban exploration groups that's
interesting
have sought publicity and or notoriety
you have not put law for what special a
publicity ownership are busy and Hosea
think it was the paprika right so
they're they made me pourquoi tu papa
bouba city ah connect no distance seemed
simple father capacities but happy
importance activity last week show go
beyond the stands that corresponds with
more power open the cop cabs and
publicity no escape for fair parking
Association what is not saw in the intro
city right so many kind of organizations
benefit from publicity but clandestine
organizations do not
noted I remember when the Navy SEALs
were a clandestine organization that
changed question do you have blueprints
how do you find your way around other
maps charts of the underground are their
blueprints of the buildings or do you
create your own maps no no people do
totally blown Susilo faster faster
meaner yeah you don't is na kotoba still
illogical to dip lonely Italy exists to
develop Republican don't confuse edct
evil me for example a Sun spirit EEPROM
- I exist on kita insignia play so one
of the first things the group did in the
80s was to gather as many maps as they
could and for the most part there were
maps to be had if you knew how to get
them and you know they did a certain
amount of work in sort of collating them
all and integrating them all and making
them work together but they yeah there
were maps as far as they know no one had
ever actually gone and tried to assemble
them together into one big map of
underground Paris - what is UX for do
you consider the public service the
things you said it sounded like this was
in a sense of public function not a
better service public from Empire shows
convocation utt public FISC you par
definition so facts IDO to the Provost
clandestine don't Republic nonprofit
versus Ipsy para nós kisses it
conservative shows typical despise the
personal profiles of Kurds were
community public right so they don't
think of themselves as a public service
they do these things because they want
to and
they're sort of basically inhibited by
the by being a non public organization
they can't really work for the public
you know it's what they do is they try
not to do things that would be harmful
to the public by basically just pursuing
their own objectives Jamel asks so we've
heard about the clock we've heard about
the underground cinema
are there other projects from the past
that you can talk about or describe I
expect that be another group that
follows these guys around in that
Richard Lee s was the new movie Hugo the
book and movie though is that inspired
by UX do we know this is kind of the
whole underground clock fixing and the
surreptitious Stefano probably he hasn't
seen it you know Oh exactly if see it I
think he liked it
many of his part of the hackers
conference back in 1983-84 and and it
became a continual thing that went on
for now many decades but the age of
hackers that the hackers conference
basically gets older by one year per
year and there's there's some young
people coming in but but not so much
it's mostly in an old group is the age
of your group getting older as time goes
by or is there young recruitment coming
in response kappa yep I'm on the the
tunnels the deficit CCS in spot when you
would the large second entrance in the
set isettas wasn't it
ma'am non viscous liquid debris bonuses
and concern a concern Jim the person
they don't get the treasure
fix to corrosion may other side is
hidden kappa in town there's particular
mop result so numbers range in age from
7 to 77 and you know they began at a
certain you know with a certain age
bracket which is to say 12 to 14 year
olds and but at this point basically
there's a wide diversity of Ages and
there isn't really one particular age
bracket that dominates that's very
unusual that the actual age the cohort
would would not only get older but the
other would grow in such in an age to
younger than originally and older than
originally that's pretty interesting
Laura Walter asks any recommendation for
preservation of intangible cultural
heritage or what do you mean by that
digital stuff
so come on preserve a the show's keep
the Stompa exist a physic more he saw
schwa digital super fascist sycophant
notice a problem
om ski skinny Basque in a pad existence
physique icky naked the deformation
didn't aim to complex report the the
kitchen with a very vocal new dolly
shows school school schools and we can
proceed the preservation material
separate to Dorado the technique don't
rob the server fellowship we took my
powder para pratik con Valley preserve a
perfectly suit easy me papa
correcta for my sake so preserving
things that are non tangible is start
out by saying well it's very good
question very difficult and you probably
know better than he does how to do it
one thing that they are particularly
interested in is preserving things that
are not objects but are skills that are
trades that you know crafts that are you
know in danger of disappearing examples
[Laughter]
there's some artists here I can in fact
art historian Scott ether Smith asks was
his UX influenced by the Situationists
works activities in the 1960s and beyond
no yep Adam the manifest need not all
strong near to stick in philosophy
Sango can exist appearances experience
key countries a dude who's experienced a
panda suit
simple since key fit on all of you today
all right so unlike say the situation
Situationists you X has no end goal
there's no manifesto be a philosophical
or artistic it's it exists it exists
basically to continue experiments and
experiences so kappachu dilemma key so
these are each experience leads to the
next one it's a it's a consecutive
series it's a process
paying attention to cultural heritage as
you do do you have a sense that you were
part of a continuity going back in what
you do as well as what you value to to
persuade you perceive a Etra Donson
tradition the remote trail home well
before tsunami AED mmm the preservation
in DSC the Bach Chaconne a plaintiff
from traditional okay Sileo sulphate
arrested it was Jupiter ERISA Bianca an
apology from tribes it pretty Arrington
did preservation CD the Calcasieu ski on
destroyed evidence part of a
conservative vote pass a devote the
devotee unknown so the idea of
preservation of conservation is very old
idea you know they certainly see a canoe
that although he would argue that that
conservation is not even really an idea
it's just fun something that naturally
arises when you develop an affection for
something or bury it and forget it
so in a way this is revived affection
that that you guys are doing things are
forgotten their neglected and then you
find them and fall back in love with all
which is an interesting discontinuity of
through time so that your finders we you
decode young interest and this this
community say Kate entire song SATA to
occur
dishes day wrong
mayo sweet on sweet calamari
squeezes key Rivera prepare dishes Eve
yondu Passaic River disco prism right so
yeah anything by definition anything
that survives to the present has to be
continually renewed it has to enjoy
continually renewed affections this is a
rare public event for you to what do we
owe the honor
why are you showing us this video and
talking to a public audience here today
[Music]
dishes from the rock on you
occurred is evoke in my pre complicated
exhibition did this experience about the
week's excellent doesn't Discover Allah
except we contributed with many a
positive Japan resonant room doesn't per
favore don'ts also a gob grande Stony
Point so city secret in the community
per may epithermal captures the editor
Cornelia but resumed okay so a
clandestine group is not a secret
society and when they can talk about
something because it's already become
known they're happy to especially if
they can contribute to some kind of
positive discussion that could result in
positive things so the group decided
together to accept this invitation and
since laws are is the public face of the
group the spokesperson became
why don't you come because he insisted
[Laughter]
thank you both this has been a great
honor
[Applause]
[Music]
you